Salut ! Habituellement le mardi je fais un tour à quelqu’un, je mentalise quelqu’un.
Mais un événement m'oblige à changer le calendrier de la chaîne aujourd'hui.
Puisqu'il y a quelques jours, dans les commentaires de la vidéo n°163, je lis un petit pavé, intéressant, et là...
c'est le brame !
J'hésite d'abord à répondre longuement à ce commentaire,et j'me dis qu'il y a peut-être mieux à faire : répondre publiquement, par vidéo.
Puisque peut-être que d'autres personnes pensent la même chose.
Donc j'ai demandé à l'auteur du commentaire si je pouvais le prendre en photo pour le publier dans une vidéo. Il m'a dit "ok". Lisons le ensemble.
"Je me pose tout le temps la même question quand je te vois t'exténuer, c'est pourquoi tu fais ça ?
Ok quand bien même tu réussis à faire une vidéo pendant un an tous les jours quel est l'intérêt ?
J'avais pensé au début que c'était pour augmenter ton nombre d'abonnés, mais au bout de 6 mois la progression n'est pas très forte."
Huh, prends ça !
"Je veux bien que tu fasses ça par passion mais bon, est ce que ça en vaut vraiment le coup ?
Même si tu réussis et que c'est une victoire personnelle, t'auras perdu tellement,
je pense que ça doit te coûter de l'argent de faire des vidéos tous les jours et par dessus tout tu dois consacrer un temps fou pour faire ça.
Un temps que tu aurais pu passer à t'amuser à prendre du bon temps, à te détendre... Je ne t'incite pas à arrêter."
Un petit peu quand même non ?!
"Je ne t'incite pas à arrêter YouTube loin de là juste peut-être éventuellement dans la possibilité que d'arrêter ce challenge et faire 3 vidéos par semaine.
Comme ça tout le monde est content, tu auras du temps pour toi et on aura des vidéos de très grande qualité, même si pour la plupart, elles le sont déjà !
Donc merci ! Merci, parce que c'est pas du tout agressif comme commentaire, il n'y a pas de soucis, je comprends ce que tu veux dire.
D'où l'envie de répondre en vidéo à tous ceux qui pensent la même chose que toi ou en tout cas certaines parties.
Je vais reprendre point par point.
Déjà le mot "exténuer". Alors j'ai peut-être l'air fatigué dans les vidéos c'est vrai que des fois je suis fatigué quand je le fais, parce que je filme tôt le matin ou tard le soir.
Mais le reste de ma journée, je te rassure, ça va. Je ne suis pas exténué !
Par contre ça m'oblige à avoir un rythme de sommeil où je dois faire un petit peu attention, puisque sinon je me crève vite c'est vrai dans le temps.
C'est déjà arrivé avec les dates de tournées en même temps que j'étais un peu K.O parce que j'avais pas anticipé les vidéos à l'avance.
Maintenant, je fais plus la même chose.
Quand j'ai  des choses très conséquentes de prévues sur 1, 2 ou 3 jours, en général des dates de tournées donc, alors je prépare quelques vidéos à l'avance.
Quel est l'intérêt de faire une vidéo par jour pendant un an si ce n'est le défi personnel ?
Alors contrairement à ce que tu pensais, c'était pas forcément de gratter un nombre d'abonnés plus grand,
parce que mon objectif à la base, était d'avoir 12 000 abonnés à la fin de l'année.
Si je parle d'objectif en terme d'abonnés, disons que je m'étais dit :
"Si j'ai au moins en moyenne 1 000 abonnés par mois ça va, il y a quand même des gens que ça intéresse !"
L'objectif n'était pas de grossir comme ça le nombre d'abonnés.
Tu vois je suis, au moment ou je fais la vidéo je dois être presque à 16 000.
Donc cet objectif là est largement dépassé.
Mais l'objectif premier c'était de me stimuler à écrire.
Dans l'une des FAQ, j'explique que j'écris mon nouveau spectacle en ce moment, qui va sortir au mois de janvier l'année prochaine sur une tournée de rodage
Où il y a déjà 80 dates de calées.
Plus après le festival d'Avignon en 2017, plus encore d'autres choses derrière.
Et le fait de m'obliger à sortir une vidéo par jour pendant un an,
je suis obligé d'aller puiser au fond de moi-même pour trouver des sujets à aborder, des idées, des choses que je sais que j'ai oublié.
Ca me permet aussi de voir les sujets qui vous plaisent le plus ou pas, pour voir si je les aborde dans mon spectacle ou pas.
Ca m'oblige à créer des tours et des effets pour après les amener peut-être différemment sur scène.
Ca m'oblige à créer du matos en permanence !
Sur scène quand on monte un nouveau numéro on dit qu'on crée du nouveau matériel.
En faisant ça, en faisant ces vidéos, je suis en train de créer un matériel monstrueux, ou en tout cas une pré-matière
que je n'aurais pas forcément trouvé tout seul, devant la feuille blanche durant les séances de travail.
Et alors ça c'est merveilleux je ne regrette pas du tout.
Si j'avais annoncé que je faisais deux vidéos par semaine ou 1 vidéo par semaine,
je me connais, je pense que j'aurais pas forcément tenu.
J'aurais forcément trouvé une bonne excuse à un bon moment pour commencer à décaler, à décaler...
Le fait d'annoncer publiquement, que je m'engage à faire une vidéo par jour, je sais que ça, par contre, je ne le lâcherai pas.
Parce qu'il y a aussi l'ego qui joue derrière et je veux le faire, je veux réussir ça !
Donc, est ce que ça vaut vraiment le coup ? Oui !
Quand bien même je continuerai à faire mes 300 vues par jour comme je faisais au mois de janvier,
je serais quand même très content de faire ces 300 vues là.
Les personnes avec qui je discutais dans les commentaires au mois de janvier, je vous retrouve encore, oui, vous là qui êtes là,
dans les commentaires des vidéos aujourd'hui, sur Facebook, Twitter , sur Snap...
Il y en a certains d'entres vous qui sont venus me voir en spectacle.
Je trouve ces relations-là géniales, donc ça vaut le coup.
Ca vaut le coup et puis il y a tout ce que ça amène à côté aussi.
Toutes les personnes que j'ai rencontrées en plus.
L'autre jour je vous ai fait une vidéo sur la zone de confort, c'est exactement ce que j'ai fait.
J'en suis sorti donc je rencontre des nouvelles personnes, un nouvel univers, une nouvelle manière de penser.
D'autres choses aussi que ça amène. Je suis en train de faire des vidéos pour le groupe payer pour le chaîne notre famille.com.
Ca c'est les vidéos du Mental Vlog  qui m'ont amenées ces propositions-là.
Donc je te le dis, je te le répète, ça vaut le coup !
Ensuite tu dis que peut-être j'aurais perdu tellement, j'aurais perdu beaucoup.
Peut-être que vous aussi, derrière votre écran vous vous dites ça, que je perds beaucoup à faire ça.
Alors en terme d'argent, je ne perds rien réellement, d'ailleurs je ne gagne rien ou en tout cas pas grand-chose.
Pour être très honnête avec vous, je fais 150 dollars de revenus YouTube par mois.
Dans ma société, donc ça veut dire qu'une fois les charges passées, les impôts société, si je veux le transformer en salaire net, il va me rester à peu près 50€.
Je ne paye personne, le matériel que j'ai ici, c'était du matériel que j'avais déjà.
Et effectivement le seul investissement réel que je fais en permanence, c'est l'investissement de mon temps personnel.
Alors pour ça aussi j'ai rusé.
C'est-à-dire que je me lève un petit peu plus tôt qu'avant, et je me couche un peu plus tard qu'avant.
Donc je prends sur ces moments là. Et des moments où je geekais ou je glandouillais, ou j'étais juste sur l'ordi à rien faire.
C'est-à dire même pas à jouer ou à faire un truc intéressant, à rien faire.
Ces moments là je les ai rapprochés, je les ai condensés, et c'est les 4 à 6H que j'utilise par jour pour faire mes vidéos.
Des fois c'est un petit peu plus court, 2H30-3H00 et en général c'est 4H.
Donc je passe autant de temps à m'amuser, à me détendre, à passer du bon temps.
Je sors encore le soir, je vois encore mes amis, mais oui, le rythme est plus soutenu, plus dense,mais je le gère, je crois intelligemment.
Donc je n'arrêterai pas de faire les une vidéo par jour, parce que ça m'apporte beaucoup.
Ca m'apporte aussi dans la relation que j'ai avec la caméra, qu'était pas quelque chose sur lequel j'avais l'habitude avant.
Même m'exprimer face à une caméra.
Je sais m'exprimer sur scène mais pas forcément devant un objectif.
Maintenant je crois que ça commence à s'améliorer.
Par contre il y a deux choses que je peux vous dire par rapport à tout ça, c'est que oui, l'année prochaine il y  aura moins de vidéos.
Il n'y en aura pas une tous les jours.
Mais justement pour les mêmes raisons que Asiva invoque.
C'est-à dire j'aimerai faire moins de vidéos mais un peu plus poussées.
Un peu plus riches aussi en terme de contenu, en terme de décors en terme de sujets que j'aborde, en terme de montages, de réalisations.
Donc il y en aura forcément un peu moins mais elles seront mieux écrites et mieux produites.
Bon, en attendant il reste quand même 200 vidéos du Mental Vlog à faire.
Et la seule question que je me suis vraiment posée sur laquelle Asiva n'a pas tout à fait tort,
c'est: toute l'année est ce que c'est intéressant ?
Alors l'été pas forcément parce que l'été apparemment, il y a beaucoup moins de personnes qui regardent YouTube.
Ce n'est plus le même rythme.
Les youtubers aussi sont un petit peu tout smouth, en pause.
Quoique "Les Questions Cons" faisait toujours une vidéo par semaine et elles étaient toujours aussi bien.
Alors moi je veux pas m'essouffler cet été, je ne veux pas non plus cramer des sujets hyper intéressants
que vous n'allez pas trop regarder parce qu'elles ne seront pas produites au bon moment.
Donc je commence à avoir des idées il y aura sûrement 1 ou 2 formats un peu spéciaux qui j'espère vous plairont pour cet été.
Ou au moins durant 30 jours, durant tout le mois d'août, on va voir comment on va s'organiser.
Mais je vous en reparlerai juste avant.
Asiva, merci beaucoup pour ce commentaire qui m'aura permis de faire cette vidéo,
et puis aussi moi de prendre du recul par rapport à la chaîne et de me poser des questions, en me disant : et si il avait raison ?
Et peut-être que vous aussi vous vous posiez toutes ou une partie des mêmes questions que posait Asiva.
Et comme ça je vous ai répondu à vous aussi en même temps.
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé la vidéo.
Vous êtes comme ça, ne changez rien, la chaîne c'est aussi grâce à vous qu'elle tient et que je suis toujours hyper motivé à le faire.
Rassurez vous, je ne suis pas épuisé de toute fatigue.
Vous pouvez laisser un petit commentaire en bas, si ce n'est pas déjà fait vous pouvez vous abonner à la chaîne.
Puisque le Mental Vlog, Asiva l'a dit, c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
Donc rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !